oui
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
consacrée aujourd'hui haïti un pays
accablé par de nombreux maux
l'assassinât politique la corruption
l'état failli les gangs et même des
catastrophes naturelles qu'on connaît
comme les séismes alors quel avenir pour
haïti bien pour nous en parler j'ai le
plaisir de recevoir jean marie théodat
qui est maître de conférences en
géographie à l'université de la sorbonne
bonjour jean marie théodat vous êtes
également
l'écrivain écrivain auteur du livre
haïti république dominicaine une île
pour deux aux éditions karthala merci
d'accepter notre invitation
je vais d'abord parler avec vous d'un
choc récent qui a évidemment ému le
monde entier
l'assassinât du chef d'état en exercice
jouvenel moïse le 7 juillet dernier
alors il a été abattu à son domicile par
un commando et donc l' enquête a arrêté
quarante quatre personnes dont 12
policiers haïtiens 18 colombien deux
américains d'origine haïtienne et même
la sécurité générale du palais national
est accusé d'avoir participé
êtes vous surpris par l'ampleur de ce
complot
d'abord merci de l'invitation est
effectivement l'actualité récente encore
placer haïti sur le devant de la rampe
avec cet assassinat
terrible tellement inattendu du
président genin brise que l'on se
demande comment cela a été possible dans
un pays où en dépit de toute la dérive
quand même sécuritaire que nous avons
connues sur ces deux ou trois dernières
années il était pour tout le monde à peu
près dix ont un certain que l'on puisse
s'en prendre à la personne du président
d'autant qu'il était souvent considéré
comme l'instigateur lui-même des
violences aveugles qui s'abattait sur
les quartiers périphériques de la
capitale donc c'est une activité inédite
parce que cela fait plus de cent ans que
l'on avait assisté à l'assassinât d'un
président de la république en haïti
généralement en dépit de l'instabilité
politique concerne nécessité surtout à
leur départ en exil mais un assassinat
aussi brutale aussi sanglant c'est un
c'est un véritable choc sur le plan
médiatique et sur le plan symbolique en
haïti oui bien sûr la population est
très affectée alors un homme a été
suspectée christian emmanuel sanon un
médecin en exil en floride qui est aussi
un opposant à moïse jouvenel mais vu
l'ampleur du complot on dit que c'est
pas forcément lui totalement le
commanditaire une piste une nouvelle
piste qui a émergé et celle d'un complot
de trafiquants de cocaïne et d'héroïne
qui seraient couverts par les plus
hautes autorités du pays que pensez vous
de cette interprétation
lorsque l'on établit la cartographie de
les différentes personnes impliquées
dans cet assassinat on parle donc d'un
commando constitué essentiellement de
militaires ou d'anciens militaires
colombiens de d'ordre qui serait parti
de miami dans le cadre d'une association
qui agit directement en floride et avec
probablement des ramifications en haïti
cette cartographie ressemble à s'y
méprendre à celle du trafic de drogue
qui passe généralement depuis les andes
vers la floride en passant par les
antilles et donc
on peut effectivement considérer qu'il y
à une telle superposition que cette
superposition pourrait induire une
certaine une certaine intégration entre
les deux entre les deux événements en
tout cas il est évident aujourd'hui et
surtout lorsqu'on écoute les la façon
dont le cas est traité par le regarde de
près c'est le caracol qui est un organe
de presse que l'on vient et par lequel
nous voyons apparaître des informations
très critique sur le comportement non
seulement de la du gouvernement
colombien mais de ces
sociétés qui agissent
avec plus ou moins le le blanc seing des
autorités établies pour finalement
déstabiliser un pays étranger un pays
ami donc
hérité dans lesquels on peut recruter
des sorts de mercenaires qui vont
effectuer de base offre donc comme par
exemple l'assassinât d'un dirigeant
absolument des des sociétés qui sont
censés assurer la sécurité du président
mais qui ont accès à des stocks d'armes
qui peuvent accéder à des passe droits
pour pouvoir
pénétrer certains bâtiments certains
édifices publics que l'on se demande
s'il ne s'agit pas d'un état dans l'état
donc autant d'éléments qui laissent à
penser que l'état de droit a été
véritablement mise à mal et que les
normes officielles ont été largement
outrepassé pour permettre l'assassinât
sur un mode de crapuleux du président de
la république injuste s'est dessaisi de
cette affaire au bout quatre jours alors
on parle de la justice il ya des soucis
la garde nationale également est ce
qu'il ya des institutions qui tiennent
en haïti
le problème que il y à une telle
il y un tel discrédit du gouvernement il
y à intel une telle vacances de l'état
que nous pouvons difficilement faire
confiance à la justice faire confiance
aux parlementaires faire confiance aux
magistrats pour véritablement permettra
un tel dossier d'aboutir c'est dire que
nous sommes véritablement en droit
aujourd'hui compte tenu des cas récents
qui ont été
classées sans suite je pense à l'avocat
de l'ancien bâtonnier de port-au-prince
m montferrier normal je pense à la sas
l'assassinât de
notre net duclair de diego charles des
journalistes qui étaient très remontés
contre le gouvernement donc autant de
cas sur lesquels la justice a failli et
aujourd'hui nous voyons difficilement
comment face à un cas aussi solennelle
est aussi important et puissent elles
puissent se montrer véritablement à la
hauteur on va revenir un peu dans
l'histoire il ya eu la dictature des
duvalier de 57 ans 86 90 en tout cas
cette période le coup d'état contre le
président aristide pour ne rien arranger
le 06/02/2010 ensuite la corruption du
président martelly dont finalement est
ce qu'il ya eu une période de stabilité
en haïti est ce que ça a été est ce que
ça existe est
difficile de parler de période de
stabilité déficit de parler même deux
périodes je dirais de reconstruction en
fait depuis 1986
l'opposition et tous ceux qui voulaient
éviter le retour à la dictature ont
surtout mis en place des garde-fous avec
une constitution de 1987 qui interdit
par exemple le renouvellement
automatique d'un mandat lorsque l'on a
été vu et autant d'éléments qui
fragilise la le
on va dire l'exécutif dans la
répartition des pouvoirs et autant de
mesures qui ont également empêché
l'émergence d'un leadership
véritablement nationale de sorte que
nous avons assisté depuis 1987 à une
véritable dilution des responsabilités à
une véritable déconstruction de l'état
en tant que appareils de deux
d'organisation mais également en tant
qu'appareil dépressif il nous faut pour
bien qu'en 1995 il ya eu abolition de
l'armee qui était le dernier recours
non seulement pour défendre les
frontières nationales mais également
pour éventuellement empêcher que des
éléments associés au 2e face on va dire
main basse sur les institutions et on
empêche le fonctionnement normal de la
de la démocratie donc autant d'éléments
pour dire que depuis 1987 non seulement
il n'y a pas eu et il n'y a pas eu de
stabilisation mais il y a eu
véritablement des constructions
dissolution des oeufs des forces vives
de l'état et c'est ce qui explique
qu'aujourd'hui il se retrouve totalement
en état de faillite mais dans ce que
vous dites c'est pour finalement éviter
la dictature et bien ça n'a pas permis
l'émergence d'une nouvelle démocratie
dont ce que ce que vous est ce que vous
pensez également qu'il n'y a pas de
leader de nouvelles figures qui pourrait
incarner l'avenir d'haïti
de nouvelles figures qui pourrait
incarner l'avenir d'haïti il y en a je
pense que le c'est plutôt le contraire
il y en a trop il y a une il ya une
concurrence mais une concurrence qui ne
s'est pas exercer avec des des
programmes qui ne n'a pas eu le temps de
se mûrir en se frottant véritablement à
l'exercice de responsabilités publiques
de sorte que nous avons un pays où le
personnel politique change
pour ainsi dire très peu parce que ce
sont les mêmes qui sont aux commandes
depuis au moins aujourd'hui une
quinzaine d'années et qui part
des
passe droits peut-on dire
continue de contrôler le pouvoir de
contrôler les rênes du pouvoir et nous
avons besoin en fait d'un véritable
changement à la tête de l'état nous
avons besoin de nouvelles têtes de leurs
besoins de nouvelles compétences pour
essayer autre chose parce que jusqu'à
présent tous ceux qui se sont essayés à
l'exercice du pouvoir ont échoué
l'actuel président par intérim ariel
henry a demandé aux états unis avant les
élections de mettre le pays sous tutelle
alors est ce que cette aide qui est
évidemment une dépendance et souhaita
pour haïti
alors la difficulté
opiné sur cette décision vient de fait
que
c'est une décision tellement solennelle
qu'il faudrait avoir un véritable mandat
pour pouvoir proféré une telle ou telle
une telle demande aux états unis et
c'est dire donc toutes choses étant
égales par ailleurs monsieur ariel henry
vu les conditions de son accession au
pouvoir a le un comportement un peu
léger un peu cavalier il va un peu trop
vite il n'a pas un mandat suffisamment
mûre pour faire une proposition si
solennel un pays étranger parce que ça
veut dire concrètement mettre entre
parenthèses la souveraineté nationale et
ceux ci seul quelqu'un mandaté du mans
par le peuple avec peut-être un
programme explicite pourrait faire une
telle proposition
donc cela nous paraît une mesure hâtives
et mesure imprudente et surtout une
mesure très peu patriotique parce que
cela veut dire concrètement que ils ne
sont pas capables de faire le travail et
c'est une façon très paradoxale d'entrée
en fonction que de tout de suite appelé
à l'aide au motif que le pays n'est pas
capable de faire face à ses
responsabilités
mais sachant que toute aide à un revers
alors jean marie théodat nous allons
marquer une courte pause on se retrouve
juste après
[Musique]
de retour avec le spécialiste d'haïti
jean marie théodat qui nous parle de la
crise dans ce pays alors monsieur
théodat il ya un autre fléau qui mine le
pays malheureusement les gangs il y en a
environ une centaine 3000 hommes et 500
milles qui circulerait 500 mille armes
pardon qui circulerait illégalement dans
le pays les assassinats et kidnappings
sont à leur quotidien comment ont-ils pu
à ce point se développer ces dernières
années
alors l'activité des gangs n'est pas une
activité inédite en haïti se lasser cela
commençait au à l'aube des années 2000
déjà sous le président aristide nous
avons vu apparaître les chimères mais on
pourrait dire même une décennie avant au
début des années 90 avec les un grain
d'eau qui étaient des supplétifs
finalement les militaires qui
s'accrochait au pouvoir et qui ne
trouvaient pas d'autre moyen pour
terroriser la population aujourd'hui
avec justement cette dilution
dissolution de l'armée en 1995 et
finalement l'incapacité de la police
d'assurer la sécurité publique l'on a vu
proliférer dans le pays des agences de
sécurité avec des armes plus ou moins
lourdes et certaines se spécialisant
dans la protection des sites industriels
ou tout simplement des hommes politiques
l'ont a vues en fait se constituer des
armées privées qui aujourd'hui ont
totalement perdu le contrôle de leur
trou avec des gangsters qui
s'autoproclame chef de quartier et qui
parfois terrorise la population
et lorsque ces gangsters sont recrutés
par des hommes politiques pour exécuter
leurs basses oeuvres ça vous donne une
situation pratiquement de guerre civile
on pourrait dire une guerre civile de
très basse intensité parce que les cas
ne sont pas délimitées par une barrière
idéologique par une barrière
confessionnelle ou même par les intérêts
de classe mais si ce n'est que là chacun
chacun de ces groupes essaye de définir
une portion du territoire sur laquelle
elle va faire régner ça règle sa loi et
c'est ce qu'on appelle en fait une
fédéralisation du territoire haïti est
dans une situation de
2,2 d'éparpillement féodal des principes
qui normalement sont là va dire la
structure même de
de l'état donc ça se traduit comment sur
le terrain en fait les groupes qui
kidnappe et d enlèvement il ya des
quartiers qui sont un peu à feu et à
sang
cela se traduit par des groupes de
jeunes qui sont entre
17 et une trentaine d'années parce que
je voulais c'est une c'est la catégorie
la plus vulnérable celle qui subit de
plein fouet
les effets du chômage de l'absence de
formation et finalement de l'absence
d'emploi et ses jeunes m coupe réglée
des parts quartiers entiers du taux de
la ville par exemple tout le faubourg de
martissant à la sortie sud de port au
prince est devenu aujourd'hui une zone
de non droit alors ça va quand même très
très loin ce phénomène de gangs 1 c'est
un des chefs de gangs à l'ex policier
dit michel résidus barbecue a même pris
la tête d'une coalition de neuf bang il
tient des discours politiques en fait
populiste qui le veut révolutionnaire ça
peut aller jusqu où selon vous un monde
parallèle politique mafieux
que un chef de gang aujourd'hui prennent
la tête d'une coalition pseudo
révolutionnaires et décide de donner
l'exemple on va dire d'une régénérer
régénérescence de l'étang haïti c'est
une véritable mascarade c'est une
caricature de révolution c'est cela
relève d'un cynisme véritablement son
nom parce que nous savons parfaitement
que ces gens nous connaissent d'autres
lois que celles de la violence ne
connaissent d'autres principes que celui
de la
du du gain de l'argent et surtout ne
connaissent pas d'autre intérêt que
leurs intérêts personnels donc ceci ne
peut amener à citer qu'eux le chaos
lorsque nous savons que la plupart de
ces jeunes vivent dans des zones où le
seuil de pauvreté
où plus de 60% voire 80% de la
population vit en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté c'est à dire avec moins de deux
dollars par an on se demande comment ces
jeunes arrivent à se procurer non
seulement les armes les munitions pour
pouvoir s'entraîner c'est dire par
conséquent qu'il y a des mains cachées
qui glisse ses armes ces engins de mort
entre les mains de ces jeunes et c'est
là le véritable souci quelle est la main
cachée derrière cette déstabilisation de
l'état en haïti vous pensez à quoi vous
pensez à des politiques ou à des
influences extérieures d'autres pays
on ne peut pas introduire des armes dans
les pays de la caraïbe stylet une
complicité avec ceux qui surveillent et
ceux qui ont le contrôle de la région on
ne peut pas introduire des armes dans un
pays aussi pauvre sans qu'il y ait
quelqu'un qui paye pour que ces armes
puissent être introduites et enfin on ne
peut pas introduire de telles quantités
d'armes dans un pays s'il n'y a pas
derrière des intérêts juteux qui
justifie la présence de ces armes et
surtout une telle violence c'est à dire
par conséquent que nous sommes ici au
coeur d'un système extrêmement un
briquet d'intérêt à la fois intérieure
et extérieure de toute façon
mafieux parce que cela ne relève pas de
l'intérêt commun cela ne relève pas non
plus d'activité régaliennes cela ne peut
peut contribuer à la dé construction
d'un état moderne et démocratique alors
un autre problème un désolé de faire une
litanie de problèmes et à l'occasion de
l'assassinât de jouvenel moïse on on
parle de l'appui de la piste des
narcotrafiquants est ce que c'est un
élément important de l'économie
parallèle en haïti le narcotrafic
le marco trafic n'est pas une nouveauté
non plus un haïti voilà déjà une dizaine
d'années que l'on considère qu' environ
25 à 26% de la drogue qui passe de la
cordillère des andes vers les états unis
transitent par haïti et la république
dominicaine
dire donc que par sa porosité la
frontière entre haïti et la brique
dominicaine constitue une véritable
passoire et l'effondrement de l'état
haïti l'incapacité de la marine
haïtienne de l'aviation est tout
simplement des autorités judiciaires a
assuré un état de droit dans le pays
constitue une véritable aubaine pour les
trafiquants de tout de tout de tout
ordre et haïti est considérée comme une
je dirais un chaos opportun pour
permettre justement de pratiquer des
activités illicites en toute légalité
apparente alors derniers problèmes en
date le séisme de magnitude 7 de
magnitude 7 dans le pays qui a causé la
mort de 2200 personnes alors bien
entendu on est très loin du terrible
bilan de 2010 du séisme qui avait
provoqué la mort de trois cent mille
personnes près de 300000 morts c'est un
drame de plus est-ce que avec l'aide
humanitaire il va se passer le même
problème qu'en 2010 à savoir qu' elle
avait a priori été détournés vous nous
en parlera et selon les chiffres ont dit
que seul 1% des fonds qui ont été
données par l'épée les pays dans le
monde ont été gérés par l'état haïtien
est ce que c'est vrai et comment ça peut
se passer aujourd'hui
il y a de l'expérience de 2010 à un
certain nombre de leçons à retenir la
première de leçons retenir et d'un point
de vue sanitaire nous avons été
malheureusement témoin de l'introduction
en 2010 en haïti du prion responsable
d'une épidémie de choléra qui a tué
entre 10000 et 15000 personnes dans le
pays ce qui est beaucoup il ne faudrait
pas que à la faveur de la pandémie de
comines 19 l'afflux de l'aide
internationale aboutissent à un regain
de la pandémie dans le pays
ça c'est un premier élément deuxième
élément il ne faudrait pas non plus que
l'afflux de l'aide internationale s'y
est dit bien parce que les circonstances
ont changé il ne faudrait pas que
l'afflux de cette aide contribue à
déconstruire le tas comme c'était le cas
en 2010 puisqu'on sait que 90 % de la
somme allouée haïti a été en fait
distribuer aux ong ce qui fait que nous
avons eu encore une appropriation par
des multiples de d'une aide qui n'a
jamais pu véritablement atteindre les
personnes qui en avaient le plus besoin
enfin la dernière des erreurs à éviter
c'est là l'afflux dans le pays de biens
et de services qui tuent l'économie
nationale le l'a souvent fait appel à
des experts un des experts étrangers à
des jeunes issus peut-être des
meilleures universités du monde mais qui
non seulement n'avait pas d'expérience
pour comprendre ce qui se passait à
manier mais surtout n'avais pas la
vocation de rester suffisamment
longtemps pour reconstruire donc de
sorte que l'on a confondu l'urgence et
la stabilisation l'on a fait venir dans
le pays des biens des personnes et des
facilités qui pendant un certain temps
ont donné l'impression d'un certain
miracle d'une
reviviscence subite mais très vite le
soufflé est retombé et la construction
durable demande une implication de
l'état haïtien une reconstruction de
l'état haïtien et surtout l'utilisation
des ressources locales aussi bien
ressources humaines que ressources
matérielles pour éviter que en voulant
aider le pays on ne le fragilise
davantage alors justement puisqu'on
parle des de l'aide publique au
développement qui a porté par les états
unis ou d'autres pays occidentaux est
elle finalement indique à un handicap
c'est ce que vous semblez dire vous
semblez exhorté les haïtiens à se
ressaisir à faire jouer toutes les
ressources locales les personnes est-ce
que c'est envisageable tous la
remobilisation générale sur sept
envisagent
la remobilisation générale de forces
vives du pays est possible à condition
qu'il y ait un leadership engageant à
condition qu'il y ait un leadership qui
donne envie aux gens de s'engager et de
faire des sacrifices or aujourd'hui on
se rend compte que le budget de l'état
est assuré à 60% par les deux publics au
développement c'est à dire par le
soutien des principaux bailleurs de
fonds que sont les etats-unis la france
l'union européenne le canada et ses ors
aucun pays ne peut assurer durablement
son développement avec l'aide de l'état
avec l'aide de l'étranger une aide qui
n'est même pas
je dirais une aide libre et franche
parce que haïti n'a pas non plus la
liberté d'utiliser cet argent 1
selon un programme je dirais autonomes
parce que cette aide est souvent
contingenté est assujetti presque fléché
à un poste dépenses par portes de
dépenses il faut par conséquent qu'il y
ait davantage recours à
l'impôt l'état haïtien or soit à peine
10 % de ce qu'il devrait recevoir au
titre de l'impôt sur le revenu il faut
qu'il y ait en fait
une utilisation plus efficiente des
ressources propres du pays de façon à
redonner confiance à ses citoyens
redonner confiance à ses habitants et
avec 11 millions d'habitants
cela constitue une masse critique non
seulement pour une assiette fiscale mais
également pour une force de travail et
c'est suffisant pour relancer haïti à
l'histoire commune de la france et
d'haïti le pays a racheté son
indépendance en 1825 est ce qu'elle est
seule et cette histoire est ce que la
france joue un rôle constructif hors
haïti
alors depuis l'indépendance d'haïti en
1804 on peut dire que nous sommes entre
haïti et la france dans une situation de
divorce
assez assez violent avec un contentieux
aggravé lorsqu en 1825 haïti a dû verser
une indemnité suffisamment assez lourde
à la france pour dédommager les anciens
propriétaires d'esclaves c'est dire que
nous avons ajouté dans la relation entre
haïti et la france a la rancune née de
la défaite française averti hier en 1803
sur les
les satisfactions des haïtiens qui se
voit obliger de payer en plus le vaincu
aujourd'hui la france à ses intérêts
ailleurs par rapport à haïti plus tôt en
afrique plutôt en asie et accessoirement
en martinique en guadeloupe qui sont les
derniers joyaux de l' empire de la
caraïbe mais la relation avec la france
est une relation essentiellement
culturel une relation essentiellement
intellectuelle mais géopolitiquement
haïti relève plutôt de la zone des
fleurs des états unis
vous repartez vous fait des allers
retours entre paris haïti vous allez
animer prochainement un séminaire
d'urbanisme à l'université d'haïti et
reims qui a des plans de développement
urbanistique urbain bientôt dans les
années à venir
alors après le tremblement de terre de
2010 je suis rentré en haïti pour
participer à divers programmes de
relance de l'enseignement supérieur est
l'un de ces programmes c'est le
programme urba terre dans lequel nous
essayons de mettre en place un master
pour former les spécialistes en
urbanisme résilient et l'idée est de
former des jeunes non seulement dans une
discipline où il y à un véritable besoin
de compétences mais de le faire
également dans la langue vernaculaire la
langue créole de façon que la prévention
du risque se fasse dans le langage que
les personnes en situation de
vulnérabilité sont à même de comprendre
le plus spontanément et c'est la réponse
de l'université d'état d'haïti avec la
collaboration d'universités étrangères
l'université de mons université de deux
de liège l'université de paris ii merci
tu es la sorbonne nous essayons donc au
delà des frontières au delà de toutes
les différences qu'il peut y avoir entre
nos différents pays de construire à
savoir commun parce que le plus
important c'est de aider des personnes
des individus à renforcer leurs
capacités face à des aléas qui souvent
les dépasse et surtout dans un contexte
où ça ne fait pas véritablement son
travail donc c'est construire un corpus
de connaissances en partant par les
expériences le plus les plus extrêmes
pour permettre aux personnes de
renforcer leurs capacités in situ avec
les moyens du bord vous remercie
beaucoup jean marie théodat savoir
parler d'haïti de ces problèmes
endémiques mais aussi de l'avenir et de
la reconstruction merci d'avoir suivi
cette émission merci de votre fidélité
vous pouvez revoir cet entretien en
intégralité sur rtl france point tva
bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]